okay everyone Rick and Morty fans were
thrown a bone this week during their
long open-ended wait for season four in
the form of another Adult Swim April
Fool's prank last year Justin roiland
and Dan Harmon released the season three
premiere episode this year it was a
parody episode called Bush World
Adventures amazing is our reimagining of
the show created by Australian animator
Michael Cusack who made this the popular
YouTube series demo and Darren
damodaran and animated last months Rick
and Morty themed run the jewels music
video that was awesome
so yes obviously Bush World Adventures
is not a Rick and Morty episode it's not
canon the characters look way different
they have creepy eyelids Rick is crazy
jacked roiland isn't doing the voices
obviously everyone's just an extreme
version of themselves that keeps
referencing Australian stuff Rick takes
Morty on a trip to the Australian city
of cube during which they cross paths
with a bush wizard who looks like Jerry
but isn't but then it is kind of and
then they also meet a giant named uncle
Barry and well and if you just want to
see Rick scream at Morty and put him in
danger and sexually humiliate him and
make a few meta references to Rick's
disrespect of bureaucrats and
well-beloved of an accidental giant
murder and sons with scary faces and you
know gross gross little call back to the
original doc and Marty pilot if you if
you really know your Rick and Morty
history this is definitely fun to watch
it might make you miss the show which is
not actually had its fourth season
officially approved yet by Adult Swim
Justin roiland tweeted saying that they
were just waiting on the network to find
more ways to make money from the series
more how are you making money from it's
the biggest I've ever had I don't know
yeah and there's so much merch already
out there ok well the mayor of Bendigo
in real life that was a destination in
this episode has was shown bush world
adventure adventures and she wasn't
familiar with Rick and Morty and she
said she was quite staggered by the
vulgar humor and after Google search
results for the city shot up after this
episode she admit
at any publicity is good publicity but
that Bendigo is nothing like what was
displayed in the episode his Braves it
kind of boring Bendigo is like a barren
wasteland now Cusack admits that he was
he's never actually been to the city he
just picked Bendigo because the name
sounded funny ok and if anything would
buy your ankle first Bush web adventures
what you guys think of this episode did
it live up to your Rick and Morty
expectations it scared me more than most
of them it's great no it's like look I'm
Lee you my body left and it win the year
or whatever he's saying cute car utility
utility truck you don't even know you're
asking utility for me this felt like
what I imagined people who don't really
like Ricky more do don't ever watch it
is for every episode of Rick and Morty
was just like it's just like this old
man screaming at a little boy and trying
to kill them and there's a lot of
everything even if sometimes well we
don't really use truth as much anymore
pay respects but when it gets weird I
mean that's why people love Rick and
Morty is right I don't like it no my god
I did not like this I did not care for
it I love Rick and Morty I liked about
five minutes of this and then only 11 I
know oh yeah
well honestly it's like absurdist humor
like yeah be very hit or miss for me at
least and so he grabbed yeah wait did he
grab on you little soft
yeah like around there and but also it's
like five minutes of a very clear game
that I think is very funny which is the
idea that for those first five or six
minutes it was also like is Rick not
good at science and like it's all in his
head because he's like that will go
another dimension but it's like down the
street and like his portal gun is just a
normal gun and I thought that was a
really fun thing with this idea that
like Oh Rick just thinks that it like
all this like adventure stuff is
happening but he's just a crazy man
exactly yeah
but then eventually like no he does have
stuff and there are portals and stuff
and it just kind of like lost some
inspiration and just went anywhere the
dougie part in the begin in the middle
with like the rub and everything that
that was like the least interesting part
and then when he got to his uncle Barry
like that got fun again and it didn't
ended kind of strong he's dead
like this you have to like really really
love troll humor like just to troll just
like Anne we know what the joke is and
we're just like making fun of it now and
Rick and Morty does do a lot of the real
series does a lot of that and sometimes
they're really great about it sometimes
I think especially in season three there
were times where it's like okay you've
done like too much of it like 30 percent
the episode is that now when like I
think the writers just start to get a
little bored with their own premise and
I think this is all of that so I
appreciate that it was only 11 minutes
long because I think any longer I think
also part of the problem is that they're
doing it to Rick and Morty imagine if it
is to the Simpsons or something right
some it's a little bit more like
traditional and straightforward but
still very comedic but they're like
imagine the Simpsons went off the rails
like Rick and Morty goes off the rails
like yeah it already does what if it
didn't have rules though or story or
structure or anything this is it's not
what you never would ask for that but
that's what that week that's where we
got yeah but I love seeing it on stuff
that you wouldn't expect it from it's
bad yeah well let us know what you
thought about this Busch World
Adventures Rick and Morty episode do you
think it can sustain you through the
next two to eight years before another
season comes subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our Rick and Morty coverage
we actually did breakdowns about all the
episodes of season three and a bunch of
other videos about jokes that you might
have missed but knowing Rick and Maury
fans you need to miss anything anyway
thanks for watching guys bye bye